[Music]
i'm samantha wasser i'm co-founder and
president of buy chloe we really are
serving burgers and fries and and salads
things that aren't foreign to people so
i think that when someone that might not
be vegan or might not you know have
plant-based eating in their life it's a
little less intimidating for the person
to actually try it that meal is you know
helping the planet and helping your body
and it's good for you
[Music]
every day there's like different
scientists that are coming up with these
meat alternatives and you know
eventually you know we are going to run
out of a lot of what most people are
living on right now so i think that
concepts like by chloe that are
reinventing and making vegan plant-based
eating more acceptable and more to the
masses is really going to make a big
difference in our universe
[Music]
what i would say to someone that would
be afraid of a vegan or plant-based
lifestyle is really just take each day
as a step be more conscious the next
time you go to a restaurant maybe you
get a vegetable side or you get a
vegetable entree instead of having your
meat if you have the passion and that's
something that you know you want to
happen you'll definitely you know make
those changes and work towards you know
your end goal
[Music]
you